hello everyone and welcome to the London
chess classic after rest today we go
into round six and this appears to be a
game of blunders it's not just me who is
blundering today in my rapid games but
also uh the top players it would seem so
we are going to show two games in this
video rather this game we're going to
show to its fullest end the Michael
Adams game we are only going to show the
end the game he'll played against Jill
Mard as um he's the leader of the
tournament and uh well it does depend a
lot for him but also for gkes if he
wants to qualify for the candidates
tournament and then tomorrow probably I
will cover the the the you know which
game I'm talking about now let's check
out this one gesh with the wi pieces
faces off against Luke mcshain a very
strong player he's known to be the
world's strongest amateur player as even
though uh some 10 years ago he was even
a 2700 player incredibly strong and he
he also can be considered a prodigy he
got his Grandmaster title at the age of
16 back in 2000 and that was a quite a
huge deal but he does have other uh uh
you know point of interest and other
work aside from just playing chess uh
but that being said let's check it out
as this is a pretty wild game so gkes
has the wi pieces he opens with D4
Knight F6 we have Pawn to C4 E6 and now
Knight to F3 we have Pawn to D5 and
Knight to C3 we have Bishop to E7 and
now C captures and D5 so just the
Queen's gam decline fairly normal stuff
here e captures Bishop to F4 and Now
Pawn to C6 so defending on D5 uh Pawn to
E3 and now Bishop to F5 again very
standard stuff here the exchange
variation of the Queen's Gamba declined
Knight to H4 going after the bishop
Bishop to G4 attacks the queen and now
Queen to C2 we have Knight B to D7 uh
and pawn to H3 going after the bishop
here Bishop back to E6 and now Knight
back to F3 and the position has been
reached before interestingly between
param makulu and Michael Adams the same
gentleman playing in this tournament
leading the tournament was played last
year in Bundesliga and makulu won this
game with the white pieces but in that
game Adams continued with Knight to f8
however here we have Rook to C8 by Luke
and it is now as of move 11 that we have
a completely new game so maybe sort of
an an English variation of how to play
this uh we have Bishop to E2 and now
Pawn to G6 and interestingly now only
after Pawn to G6 does gush bring the
bishop over to D3 which looks uh which
looks very odd but Gish of course knows
what he is doing we have castles castles
and now Knight to H5 going after gish's
Bishop here uh Bishop to H6 and Knight
to G7 now defending this way uh Knight
to E2 and now Rook to E8 we have Pawn to
G4 stopping Pawn to F5 by Luke uh and
now Pawn to C5 when your opponent
expands on the king side it is um very
principled strike in the center and you
also have the queen on C2 so that makes
it um helpful so D captures on C5 Knight
captures on C5 and now Knight to F4 not
worried about any discoveries as you
don't really have any uh if you capture
the queen captures Knight coming to E4
isn't all that spectacular uh but here
we have Bishop to F6 a bit more precise
is Bishop to D7 as it directly stops
goer sake's idea so Bishop to F6 and now
Bishop to B5 attacking the rook and
while you could still block it with
Bishop to D7 uh Luke just brings The
Rook back to
f8 and okay Rook a to B1 now you can uh
you don't have to worry about advancing
the B Pawn The Rook will not hang on A1
uh Queen to B6 attacks the bishop and
now Queen to E2 defending and also
sidest stepping The Rook on the C5 we
have Rook F to d8 and now Knight to D4
defend and attacks on E6 we have Knight
to E8 uh and now Rook F to D1 uh just
mobilizing pieces on optimal squares we
have Knight to D6 attacking the bishop
here and Bishop back to D3 we have
Knight D to E4 centralizing the Knight
and Bishop back to C2 we have Pawn to A5
grabbing more space on the queen side
King to G2 and now Queen to C7 uh we
have Knight D capturing an E6 some
traits occur here F captures an E6 so
the queen also helps out with the
defense of the king and now Bishop
captures an E4 we have D captures an E4
offering a rook trade but Rook beat the
C1 first saying that okay if you capture
I'm going to capture with the queen and
keep the pin here so Rook captures on D1
but now Queen captures on D1 and queen
to C6 nicely aligning with the queen
with the King here B3 uh preparing uh uh
A3 and B4 and now Rook to d8 attacking
the White Queen Queen to E2 and now Pawn
to B6 uh we have Pawn to A3 now you have
to be very careful if B4 lands you're
going to lose that Knight so Queen back
to D7 and now Queen to
C4 uh and here okay there are a couple
of moves you could play you could try
going after the A3 point with some
something like Bishop to B2 you could
play Queen to F7 uh sort of set up a
defensive perimeter around this E6 Pawn
but not Luke he goes for Knight to D3
attacks the rook and just wants to
eliminate one of the attackers that will
come with Tempo but gash plays Rook to
D1 and now look at this now King to F7
is the best move here but Luke play
Knight captures on F4 this comes with
check and it looks like you're also
winning a rook but not really this move
just uh loses you the game kukish
happily takes this and now look at this
looks looks uh Queen is hanging here and
there's no good move here if you capture
then Queen captures on E6 with check
only move king h8 queen captures here
and now once the king moves this will be
Checkmate uh so after e captures on F4
uh Queen to E8 was played to guard the
E6 Pawn but now of course you know what
what happens just rook captur and d8 and
now you you're probably thinking but
okay maybe we can capture with the
bishop well yes but if you capture with
the bishop then Queen to D4 threat
threatens Checkmate and you don't have a
good move if you move the queen then
again you lose the bishop here so uh
Luke tried Queen captures uh sorry Luke
Tri Bishop captures but it doesn't uh
help uh Queen to D4 was played and now
just Pawn to E5 stopping that uh Queen
to G7 Checkmate Queen to D5 check first
and now only now after King to h8 F
captures on E5 was played and he was in
this position on move 41 that Luke
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here uh you you have a
beautiful pass Pawn you up a pawn and
but more than that there just aren't any
useful moves here to give you an example
let's say you play something you don't
even have to rush this you can uh first
defend your Pawn like you can play A4
and now you're really out of moves here
like Bishop C7 you're just going to
capture here uh or you don't even have
to do that you can play uh Pawn to E6
first and only if black decides to uh
trade now you play Queen captures you
allow a few checks but that's it after
King T2 there's really nothing here like
Queen captures even this on H6 you can
advance the pawn now the other Queen
comes into the game and very quickly you
can Checkmate the black
king uh only only one of the
possibilities now uh this is what
happened in gu's game and it means a lot
because he can overtake Adams um as the
leader of the tournament the problem is
uh this is the position from the game
jel Mard versus Michael Adams and Mard
had a completely winning position here
and he found the killer move he played
Bishop captures on F7 but after Rook
captures on E on F7 uh he blundered the
position the correct way to play this is
Pawn to F4 or Rook to B8 you have to use
both of those moves so it doesn't matter
which one you play first point is
to uh move the queen away from the
defense of the d8 square uh so after
this check is given you don't have
Bishop back to d8 defending they going
to attack the queen and once the queen
moves now you deliver a check and only
after let's say Rook to f8 now Queen to
D5 with check forces the king away from
the defense of the rook and that's it
King H7 Rook captures an f8 and you uh
win the game you you okay a few checks
will be given let's say like this but
after another check Queen E2 and that's
it you're up a you're up the exchange of
course completely winning but in the
game where Queen to E6 was played uh uh
uh thinking that it's the the exact same
idea uh but here Michael Adams had a
surprise for Jil Mard so feel free to
pause the video and try to find the only
move that saves the position for black
not just saves also wins the game while
I'll give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding this
elusive idea even a great strong Grand
Master like Jil Mard missed it and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's Bishop to E7 look at this
elegant defensive resource that Michael
played and once Jil musar saw this uh it
was in this position that he resigned
the game uh he probably thought that
after this you have to play something
like Queen to G6 but then of course
Queen to A8 check forces the king away
uh or or you block with the rook and
then you lose the queen or you move the
king and then you lose the Rook uh and
everything is winning but after this
elegant Bishop D7 there's just nothing
you can't touch the Rook you can't take
the bishop because just Queen captures
and you know it's a silly thing to miss
but uh it happens and it can even happen
in a classical game with plenty of time
on the clock uh okay I don't I don't
actually know how much time on the clock
they had so I will check I don't want to
trick you guys I know that um in the
gcash game it wasn't a problem of of
time uh but yeah here musar played it
yeah he had a lot more time he had 36
minutes on the clock Michael arens had
17 minutes so it happens so next time it
happens in my rapid games uh you know it
can happen to anyone it would seem and
next game I will I will show the game
you know which one I'm talking about the
miniature of the round so stay tuned for
that and you know um I hope hope you
enjoy that one as well uh so yeah hope
you guys enjoyed it I would like to wish
a belated happy birthday to mume and I
would like to thank David gasparian
gnome Huga boy on Spotify and schaer for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the Chess World so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day